The Joe Rogan Experience do you think
we're ever going to come to a time in
this country where internal combustion
engines are outlawed I don't think so
man I really don't I think it's I think
you're going to see that like come full
circle just in my opinion oh
outlawed or gone away because well
because alcohol was outlawed as once for
for as well yeah it take California out
of the equation though I mean that but
that's what they're doing is crazy you
can't buy new internal combustion
engines after 2035. and I think this is
like 20 something other states fixing to
adopt it the same way because you can do
it without a vote yeah it's crazy they
did it without a vote I don't think it
makes sense I really don't I don't think
there's enough minerals in the ground I
don't think they just the mining alone
that would have to happen and the the
reality of what happens in that mining
like people you need to understand what
they're talking about they're talking
about batteries like this this idea that
batteries just come from fairies and
that now all of a sudden you have this
like zero carbon impact vehicle like
that's nonsense that's complete total
nonsense you you're ignoring the entire
Supply process of what it takes to make
that what is it with people that they
don't they won't recognize that they
don't want to recognize that some people
didn't know about it until I had this
guy on my podcast said Darth Cara who
wrote a book about it and he went to the
Congo to show these illegal Minds like
what they're doing I mean it's not
illegal there's no law right but they
have children working in these mines
they have women working in these mines
with babies on their back and they're
they're mining toxic Cobalt and this
stuff is I mean there's no protection
there's no safety these people are like
chipping the [__] out of the ground and
that's a good percentage of all the
Cobalt that's involved in electronics
and batteries and cell phones and all
the things that we need and it's not
very publicized it's it's this man
exposed it and he risked his life to do
it and he wrote a great book about it
and the podcast was
it was insane like listening to his
story and how he risked his life to get
this footage and you know and there were
several times where there was men's guns
and he got questioned and he had you
know a bunch of people that were helping
him but he got out of there eventually
with this reality that everybody now is
faced with it's like this is how they
get the stuff that you need to run your
cell phone like stop thinking that you
know you have zero impact if you're
buying this you're contributing to this
we all are and we don't want to keep our
[__] heads buried in the ground and
pretend it's not happening and to say
that like everything has to be
electronic like slow down like where is
this coming from who's making it who
what what are the conditions like in the
places where these people have to put
your phone together what are the
conditions like do you know
dude Foxconn has Nets around the
building because people were jumping off
what yeah where they make iPhones they
they put Nets around the building
because so many people are committing
suicide
so instead of windows they're working
constantly they work constantly they
sleep there beds underneath their desks
or their work areas and it was sleep
underneath work sleep work show the
photo of the uh Nets around Fox it's bun
yeah look at that
you know how Wild that is like if you're
gonna jump off a building you can't do
it here get out of here or if you do you
better have a good aim man you gotta aim
for it there's no net
how do you explain that to people like
when you're walking Executives into the
building without a huge bird problem
we've had a huge bird how crazy that is
you've had so many people commit suicide
and your solution is putting Nets around
the building
those people just go up to the top floor
[__] this bang I wanted to be over just
lock them like all the casinos do
just lock the windows it's the roofs to
do maintenance there's just got to be
like better representation of both sides
so that people understand well really we
should be making phones in America and
they should be American-made American
wages where people get health and dental
and all the stuff you're supposed to get
and you have a living wage that's what
it's supposed to be and if your phone
costs a little more to do that and if
Apple makes a little less that's how
it's supposed to be you're not supposed
to be using slave labor to do stuff and
you know we don't have an ethical Choice
it's not like if you want to be a part
of today's society you kind of have to
have a smartphone if you're answering
emails and doing business it's way more
convenient to do that than not have one
and there's not like this like very
obvious ethical Choice like hey this
company only uses high-paid labor
everybody has Insurance there's none of
that if they only work x amount of hours
a day there's none of that you you get
these things and they're all
manufactured overseas
if is it 20 30 is the year is that what
California's law I think it's 20 35 yeah
if if they were to do that and say it
was Nationwide right and no new cars
after 2020 2035 can beat
but they don't touch I mean obviously
you're not gonna be able to do anything
with it what's existing any of the ice
Motors that are out there that's gonna
be like it's gonna be like Judge Dredd
yeah imagine what the cost of like a
F-150 would be worth then maybe more
desirable or less desirable I mean
there's good I mean I would assume that
at least
50 something percent of the population
is gonna be like [__] that I'm never
going that I'm gonna keep buying my yeah
my gas Motors right well the the thing
that always is going to be an issue with
uh cars is charging them takes time
right so you have to sit there so if
you're if you're fully out of juice and
you're on a cross-country trip how long
does it take when you go to those
supercharger stations to get you up to
100 again
how long is that is it a few hours yeah
longer than you want to be sitting there
yeah so damn sure with Rising crime and
having places where you know people are
going to be stuck and no security
especially in places like La good luck
with that oh yeah my friend Eddie was
telling a story the other day about he
almost got robbed at a gas station and
he realized these guys were coming
towards him and he got out just in time
but he's like you know how you you've
been in your car so many times that you
can just you know where everything is
instantly you'd have to fumble he says
if that's what saved me that I just
jumped in my car and I knew how to and I
was just moving already crazy the guy
was moving towards him dude that's a
little bit like the net scenario though
like what's the problem that we're not
solving that like quite the facts why
are you afraid to go sit there and
charge your car at the gas station well
because you're gonna get [__] robbed
for sitting there is nobody looking at
uh airline travel and the way planes are
made with doing anything away with
doing electric motors on that kind of
[__]
there's a concept that's really
currently being developed for a solar
powered plan I talked to a guy about it
like over a year ago and they were
explaining it and they they have I think
they've done a bunch of test flights and
they're you know about then it's going
to be able to go a long way
I just don't know
I don't know how that works you know I
don't know like how much how much range
does it have how safe is it like
you know you don't want why is it you
want to be an early adopter
like flying cars like you see flying
cars like yeah I'm gonna sit that out
yeah
people keep an eye on it you know yeah
how many people fly into power lines you
know how many people are going to fly
into trees and start forest fires no I
think that when they announce that in
California wasn't like the next day they
also had an announcement for people to
stop charging their cars like a week
later please don't charge that's the
other thing it was so hot it maxed out
the grid if everybody had an electric
car The Strain on the grid would be
Monumental I don't know if most grids
the way they're set up right now would
be able to handle that like if everybody
had an electric car wouldn't that take
like substantial upgrades to the grid
dude it's just infrastructure Joe we
just did you just like you just invest
in infrastructure man I like how you're
saying it like it makes sense you're so
confident you think they're worried
about all of that stuff or they know
that it's impossible that's why you push
it out to it's just looks really good on
the ballot it does look really good on
the ballot that's part of the problem
this is a lot of people these knee-jerk
reactions to like very complex nuanced
problems like the environment like I had
Mike Baker on uh yesterday and we talked
about this and one of the things you're
saying like the vast majority of the
pollution the carbon emissions in the
world is coming from China and India as
the vast majority of it and they're not
going to change they're not going to
change what they do no matter what we do
we're not going to put a dent in what
they're doing and there's a bunch of
people that think that the way to get us
out of this and the way to mitigate
climate change in terms of like human
impact on it is actually
to build up poorer communities and get
them on the electrical system get
nuclear power to these places or so or
something and like Elevate their
standard of Life you'll have less
pollution you'll have less you'll have
less Pro you'll definitely have less
issues in terms of like Health
consequences the people that live there
and
in turn as they become more you know
sustainable they live a better life
their lifestyle is better you'll have
less pollution
they just need it just people need to be
incentivized like they need to have some
sort of like there's places in the world
that have no hope and they just burn
tires they don't give a [__] right right
like they're not thinking about the
environment they're thinking about how
do I get by how do I stay alive I'm back
to your point on making stuff here I
don't know the numbers but I'm wondering
what if you were to say in 10 years
we're requiring 90 of every single thing
we use to be made in the USA right so
you cut out all that air freight and all
that that freight line all the shipping
with the shipping is huge and everyone
wants to talk about providing jobs if we
take if we take all that [__] what does
that do for the carbon footprint if
we're not shipping all those Freighters
yeah and we're building this [__] here
if you Google that and granted this is
just me like looking at Google doing
Google research but look at what is it
look at what a container ship
use uses in fuel consumption it's
[__] insane it's like the equivalent
of like every single vehicle in the
United States like in it annually like
just it seems like a huge dent you'd put
in it by us making this [__] here and
using it here that would be a big dent
that would be massive
there's I mean that's obviously a
long-term project unfortunately
manufacturing really kind of got out of
the United States
when they started shipping and building
cars overseas and and ruined Detroit I
mean Detroit just fell apart that Roger
and Me movie you guys ever see that
never said no never heard of it you
never heard of it it's um
what the [__] his name
Jamie
Michael Moore Michael Moore that guy uh
it's a great documentary and it's about
Flint Michigan it's about right after
they closed all the plants down and
everybody just had nothing they had
nothing to do and just like the city
collapsed
and all that happened because they
wanted to make [__] cheaper yeah they
wanted to pay people less and it's more
profitable for them to have uh you know
their manufacturing plants in other
countries
dude it's nuts that was and that the one
song for Whitey the other day yeah you
know Whitey Morgan
Countryside yeah I've heard the name he
was on the podcast and we went to he did
a local show and stuff like that he's
from Flint and his dad and Granddad
worked in the auto and he has a song and
it was telling about it yeah we were
talking to him about like
Michigan it came up because you know we
go to shows in Michigan and Michigan's
got a very like Southern
redneck pocket right very it's weird
because of how North it is but he talked
about all the people from the South
moved up there for completely Auto jobs
and all the wages right and it just it's
that area but he talked about the same
thing when it when they shut it down I
mean it just killed that [__]
specifically Flint that's where he's
from
it's a horrible story and they did that
because they wanted to make more money
imagine knowing that you're gonna just
destroy thousands of people's lives like
instantly I'm not like yeah I want to
make more money I'm not trying to put
you on blast I really want to know on a
normal let's see where this is going on
a normal I like how the kids say that
these days put you on blast well on a
purchasing decision when you're going to
buy something how big how does that
weigh on you knowing that it's made in
America well I'd like to buy everything
made in America if it was possible I
would like to buy everything made
somewhere where people are paid fairly
right that's what we that's like what
should be the normal ethical exchange
for everything if you go to a restaurant
you want to know that everyone's being
taken care of and paid fairly you know
you you go to you buy a car from you
guys you want to you want to pay you for
your work it's like very it's a good
Exchange
that's that's what I think I like to
think about and the thing that bums me
out is if you're buying something that
you know is made by people that are
essentially slaves yeah I mean the
people working in Fox what options do
they have like what do they do is there
an option to only work eight hours a day
no like it's probably not but it's
probably insane that using young people
to do it too
it's all [__] sketchy